hi there Steve here Steve Kaufman
remember by the way if you like my
videos please subscribe and give me
likes and stuff apparently that helps to
give you know me better ratings on
YouTube today I want about talk about
stress in language learning why it's bad
and how we get rid of stress in language
learning
amongst other things let's stop testing
people and asking them questions so a
bit of background today first of all is
July 1st and that means that it is kin
of the day it's the national holiday in
Canada so I'm wearing my red golf shirt
because I'm going to we've got a shotgun
golf tournament at the golf club for
Canada Day and everybody's supposed to
wear something red patriotic whatever
golf in golf when you are tense
you can't play well mood effects golf
tremendously but mood also effects
language learning so you know stress you
can have positive stress like I played
in a golf tournament with my hockey
buddies old-timers hockey group and
there it's a good you're all having a
good time we're playing sort of a
scramble and I did very well I hit the
ball well if I'm playing with people
that I don't like and I don't really
enjoy being out there I don't do well if
you're relaxed if you're if I'm thinking
about my swing and what I should do and
where I positioned my weight and stuff I
can't hit the ball if I feel comfortable
and relaxed I do well the same is true
in language learning and this came to me
because I went to dinner with this and
my wife and I went to dinner with this
Chinese couple that we know here and so
he of course he's an immigrant to Canada
and he's been trying to learn English
without much success although I think he
understands more than he did I tried to
get him on link he doesn't like doing
that he says he can't listen he serve
basically turns off fine so he's going
he's been going to class three hours a
day five days a week and he says very
tired and when he comes home he's tired
and stuff but he thinks he's doing well
ba
in the last say they test them every two
weeks and it turns out that he's
actually according to the tests getting
worse so he feels very depressed about
his English learning and I wouldn't say
he's he thinks he's motivated but
actually you know I try to speak to him
in English and we basically listens and
pretty soon the conversation degenerates
into Chinese so he's not successful but
telling him every two weeks that he's
getting worse in other words forcing him
to take this test is not very good
because we can do well sometimes and not
do well other times so for example in
that restaurant as we're leaving there's
a large table with Iranians so I say you
know hold its authority and I say a few
things in Iranian to them and then they
come back to me and all sudden I realize
that my efforts at learning Turkish have
basically wiped out my Iranian day it
hasn't Farsi it hasn't wiped it out but
it's just that in the pressure of the
moment I couldn't remember anything
pressure I inflicted it on myself by
speaking to them but nevertheless the
pressure to produce I couldn't produce
so then one of them says oh you're
learning Turkish I speak Turkish what
can you say in Turkish again pressure to
produce I better than anything now I
inflicted that all upon myself and I
don't mind it doesn't bother me that I
couldn't produce because I am confident
that in time I will be able to speak
Turkish and when I go back to Persian
refresh myself on my many stories find
new material eventually you know I'm in
no hurry and I will get there I'm
confident it doesn't destroy my
confidence but for this person who's
trying to learn English who has to learn
English who at some level would like to
learn English because he has emigrated
to Canada telling him that he's no good
doesn't help and and part of that is
that the whole testing thing for example
in Canada English in the English
speaking school system and I remember
this from when I went to school kids are
tested all the time and at the end of 10
years of learning French this is the
French kid French
in the English language school system
and they're tested and some kids do well
on the test and yet at the end of ten
years they can't speak French so all of
that testing and all of that instruction
really doesn't do much see what has to
happen and if I look at my Chinese
friend there he's expecting the teacher
to teach him he's not prepared to listen
and read and discover the language
somehow he wants the teacher to teach
him and so the teachers trying to teach
him and is drilling him and is testing
him with very poor results what has to
happen is that that you know language
instruction per se is almost a misnomer
what should happen is that people are
told I'm not gonna if I'm gonna teach
you I'm not gonna teach you the language
I'm gonna help you I'm going to tell you
where there are resources interesting
content at your level when you're
curious about grammar you can look up
grammar for example I look up Turkish
verbs and there's a site called Turkish
explained or explain Turkish or
something like that and it has all kinds
of good information about Turkish about
things that I am interested in I am
curious about things that I haven't
noticed in the language and when I read
those things that I'm interested in I go
haha the light goes on I understand that
when I see those structures I know why
that works that way but it's not
something that teacher has tried to
teach to me before I'm ready to absorb
it it's something that I'm interested in
so I'm exploring the language so somehow
we have to get rid of the pressure the
idea that the teachers gonna teach the
language that whatever the teacher
imposes on you you have to do including
writing the tests and somehow and I'm
I'm not a classroom teacher so I don't
know how best to do this but somehow
turn it around you're here to explore
the language whatever you discover in
the language is fine if you listen to a
content item and you understand half of
it that's fine if you misunderstand it
that's fine if you're listening the
stuff that you like the voice and you
kind of don't really understand it
that's fine you try to communicate and
you don't do
well that's fine because we can do well
sometimes and not do a lot of times so
we might do well on the test and then
not do well on the test the main thing
is to continue to engage with the
language if you continue to engage with
the language but in a situation where
you are driving the process you are
interested you are finding things of
interest now obviously here the teacher
has to help them the learner find
content of interest more or less you
know things that they have a chance of
learning we go back to that chit hack
behind me whatever this Hungarian guy
about the state of flow something that's
difficult but there is a sense that we
can achieve it either because we're very
interested in the subject or because
like even in my case I've now found
these Turkish podcasts and I go through
them which I can go to the link browser
extension bring it into link as a lesson
I go through and look up the words I
fight my way through the text and when I
listen to it I don't understand it but I
like the man's voice I'm exposed to the
language and I'm plowing through you
know I have the feeling that this
engagement with the language is helping
me no one's gonna test me on what I
understood I'm just doing that and when
I feel like it I go back to the many
stories where I understand more but the
whole point is remove the stress the
stress to perform the trust stress to
remember anything the stress to get
anything right the stress to remember
rules of grammar none of that matters
what matters is to stay active in it to
enjoy it and to believe in the process
and if you do that eventually you will
improve but that does mean putting the
sort of call it the impetus or the
responsibility on the learner and that's
I'm sure very difficult to do but maybe
that's what divides successful language
learners from not so successful language
learners they learn without stress they
put may put some pressure on themselves
but it's not a pressure to perform it's
that pressure to stay with the task
that's what I had to say and this
afternoon we'll see if I'm stressed or
not stressed while playing golf
bye for now
you